وقد اعربت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
قلقها من العنف المتصاعد بشكل حاد في
الضفه الغربيه وقلل المتحدث باسم الوزاره
نيد برايس في مؤتمر صحفي قال ان واشنطن
تواصل حث الطرفين الاسرائيلي والفلسطينيه
التي اتخاذ خطوات فوريه للحيلوله دون سقوط
مزيدا من الخسائر في الارواح
مازلنا نشعر بقلق عميق ازاء التصاعد
الحادي في العنف في الضفه الغربيه ونواصل
حتى الطرفين على اتخاذ خطوات فوريه لمنع
المزيد من الخسائر في الارواح وهذه هي
الرساله التي شدد عليها بلينكن ومستشار
الامن القومي خلال مباحثات مع الوزير
الاسرائيلي للشؤون الاستراتيجيه يوم امس
وكما قلنا مرارا فان الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين يستحقون تدابير متساويه من
الحريه والامن والازدهار